ladies and gentlemen your hosts for the
evening
james franco and anne hathaway
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh you're all real
wow this is actually happening okay
hello
and welcome to the 83rd annual academy
awards
and i must say you look so beautiful and
so hip
oh thank you james yeah you look very
appealing to a younger demographic as
well
thank you very much so here we are and
it's hollywood's biggest night
and it's very exciting for both of us
because we're both nominated
uh actually james i'm not nominated
tonight come on anne don't be so modest
no i'm not modest i'm just not nominated
you know right it used to be
you get naked you get nominated
not anymore not anymore
but enough about me james you are
nominated tonight
the best actor your first nomination
are you nervous uh no no
come on you must want to win a little
bit i mean i don't know i mean what do
you get if you win
you get an oscar yeah but do i like get
money with it or
no you get prestige for the rest of your
life
everyone will refer to you as academy
award winner james franco
what do you mean everyone like even my
mom
that'd be weird if my mom called me
academy reward winner james franco
i've known her a long time is your mom
here tonight i think yeah she's
somewhere
my mom's here too hi mom hi
my mom everybody you look so beautiful
mom
annie honey yeah stand up straight
mr steven spielberg's here honey
really mom in front of a billion people
you're gonna
yeah i'm sorry okay thank you i take the
note mommy take them on please sit down
my uh my grandma's here too how am i
doing grandma
i just saw markey merch
no no
that's actually mark wahlberg uh academy
award nominee
yes and and we loved his film the
fighter
all right it's been such a great year
for big studio pictures tiny independent
films and it's been a great year for
lesbians that's right
not just in general but in movies
the kids are all right lesbians black
swan
dancing lesbians toy story three
where's the dad
tonight we will honor the great films
and talents of the past year
and also occasionally look back at some
of the best movies in oscar history